nous allons retrouver en sénateurs qui
est en pointe sur ce dossier qui suit de
près cette affaire de la finale de ligue
des champions c'est michel savin le
sénateur les républicains de l'isère
bonjour michel savin bonjour vous
présidez notamment le groupe d'étude du
sénat qui travaille sur l'organisation
de ces grands événements sportifs vous
avez d'ailleurs demandé dans cette
affaire une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire on va en parler mais
d'abord à ces auditions aujourd'hui de
gérald darmanin et d'amélie oudéa
castéra qu'est ce que vous en attendez
de ce que nous attendons c'est des
réponses à toutes les questions qui se
posent depuis samedi samedi soir après
les événements qu'on a connus au stade
de france des réponses il soit crédible
parce que le discours qui est tenu par
le ministre de l'intérieur depuis samedi
en fléchant uniquement les supporters
anglais
est remis en cause par beaucoup de
témoignages et donc nous attendons
surtout des réponses qui soit crédible
pour et transparentes a donc voilà ce
qu'on attend et puis surtout comme l'a
dit françois noël buffet aussi on tire
des leçons de tout ce qui s'est passé
samedi pour mettre en place les moyens
nécessaires pour accueillir correctement
et dans les meilleures conditions la
coupe du monde de rugby en 2023 des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques en 2024 donc
ça veut dire que pour l'instant vous ne
croyez pas la version du ministre de
l'intérieur qui pointent surtout la
responsabilité sur ces milliers de
supporters britanniques
tout l'été beaucoup de témoignages de
personnes qui étaient présentes sur le
site une aussi des journalistes français
et internationaux qui qui démontre que
le chiffre de 30000 à 40000 supporters
présents à 21h pour le parvis du stade
de france et qui se serait évaporé
quelques quelques minutes après pose des
questions le ministre n'évoque pas ni
samedi soir d'hiver sa conférence de
presse des événements à qu'on voit en ce
moment même sur les images des groupes
de jeunes qui sont venus
perturbée agresser voler les personnes
qui étaient les supporters et
spectateurs qui étaient présents pour
venir assister à ce match il les veut
pas il n'évoque pas les
dysfonctionnements qu'on a connu dans
l'accueil aussi des spectateurs la grève
du rer qui était annoncé qu'ils étaient
prévus n'a pas été anticipée donc si on
voit dans l'invention différents
reportages que des milliers de
supporters sont arrivés sur un site qui
était engorgé et rien n'avait été
préparé pour les réorienter vers
d'autres portes d'accès donc ces
dysfonctionnements qui ont perturbé
l'accès des supporters au stade de
france samedi soir plus les phénomènes
de d'agression dalle festivités de voile
qui se font passer en voit sur les
images on a vu sur les images des
personnes escaladé les grilles est passé
à à l'intérieur du stade avec des sacs à
dos
scheer quand on part en sécurité
c'est une responsabilité de l'état on
sait on connaît les drames comme la
commune en france en 2015 la et des
jeunes les personnes sont rentrées dans
les stades sans payer un billet et sans
être contrôlé je pense que c'est une
fois d'europe et puis d'autant que le
risque aurait pu peut-être est anticipée
puisque on a appris hier qu'il y a eu
une note de police quelques jours avant
qui prévoyait l'arrivée massive de ces
milliers de supporters sans billets ça
c'est un point à
éclaircir selon vous c'est tous des
points il inspire on voit aussi les
chirac est enfin lancé et qui font
référence et un certain nombre de
contrôles qui n'ont pas fonctionné on
parle aussi d'un système informatique
qui n'a pas très bien fonctionné à aux
entrées dont contre les faux billets et
les billets qui arrivait à des
difficultés sociales et ça aussi c'est
des problèmes encore une fois moi je
trouve que il faut que le ministre de
l'intérieur soit très clair sur les
consignes apportée concernant les
chiffres qu'il a annoncé et il a l'air
de vouloir uniquement se baser sur ces
chiffres de 30 à 40 milles anglais
étaient sans billet ou avec des faux
billets sur le parvis du stade de france
avant une fois quand on voit les
rapports de snc qui nous dit qu'il n'ya
pas eu de fou lui du voyageur après 21
heures dans les transports parisiens
c'est où sont passés ces trente minutes
quarante mille supporters à s'ennuyer ou
avec des faux billets j'ai l'impression
que le ministre de l'intérieur
assure uniquement son son discours sur
sept cents à 40 milles pour faire 4
actions de tous reste des
dysfonctionnements de la malle
préparation de cet événement et puis
surtout aussi des 300 400 jeunes qui
sont venus perturber agressé et volé sur
l'eau pas remis de cette défense alors
michel savin vous avez demandé le
lancement d'une commission parlementaire
avec commission d' enquête parlementaire
au sénat sur cette affaire où on est
votre demande
vous savez que cet après midi à 17
heures nous allons auditionner
cette audition sera présidé par françois
buffet et laurent lafon les deux
présidents mais dans la commission des
lois la président de la commission de la
culture suite à ces auditions les deux
présidents france définiront la
stratégie à mettre en place ou est-ce
que ça nécessite des mois je pense à
titre personnel que ce cet événement
nécessite d'autres auditions 1 le préfet
de police la sncm et atp la fédération
française de football qui a été
silencieuse pendant trois jours et qui
assoira a sorti un
communiqué qu'ils étaient
c'est
surprenant donc
cette personne à mes yeux devraient être
entendus pour permettre encore une fois
et le françois noël buffet daddy doit
tirer deux leçons et de pouvoir à être
en capacité de pouvoir corriger le tir
pour permettre une bien meilleure
organisation de l'accueil des supporters
et les spectateurs qui vont venir par
centaines de milliers je sais grande
manifestation que sont la coupe du monde
de rugby les jeux olympiques michel
savart l'an dernier mot sur la grève des
syndicats la ratp et grève qui a élu
samedi soir qui fait partie des raisons
de cet échec et cette grève elle va être
reconduite vendredi soir pour le match
de football au stade de france france
danemark est ce que vous pensez de cette
reconduction
est boudé le groupe
existe en france moi je trouve ça bien
sûr ces événements se passe au moment où
les grandes compétitions sont organisées
en france et si vous dire aussi que ce
type d'événement peut arriver aussi au
moment de la coupe du monde de rugby et
des jeux de ma vie qui sait après le
catastrophique donc même là je crois que
le travail de paris 2004 mais aussi
surtout les autorités françaises m de
haut niveau du ministère de l'intérieur
et des forces de sécurité ce d'anticiper
ce type d'événement qui peut aussi se
produire au moment d'un grand événement
comme celui des jeux et ce que je ne
souhaite pas bien sûr j'espère que tout
le monde sera focalisée pour la réussite
pour le bo n'a que des centaines de
milliers d'étrangers qui vont venir en
france pour assister à ce grand
spectacle c'est grand spectacle sportif
donc j'espère ce sport dans les
meilleures conditions mais voilà tout
peut arriver donc il faut anticiper le
rôle d'un élu et des politiques c'est
d'anticiper et ça n'a pas été le cas
samedi soir merci beaucoup michel savin
saturday républicain de l'isère d'être
intervenu dans notre émission et on
suivra attentivement cet après midi les
auditions des ministres de l'intérieur
et des sports ou sénat sur ces incidents
du stade de france des auditions à
suivre en direct à 17h sur public sénat
ces premiers débats de notre club
territoire bonjour à tous on va et bien
débriefé un peu ce qu'a dit michel savin
avec l'enjeu de ces auditions
d'aujourd'hui cette affaire du stade de
france pascal jalabert c'est en train de
devenir une grosse épine dans le pied du
gouvernement oui très très clairement
oui et je crois que le sénateur servira
à le réseau de pointe et l'accumulation
des dysfonctionnements parce qu'il n'ya
pas une seule cause unique on le voit au
fur et à mesure des révélations et
surtout des témoignages aussi qu'il y
avait que le bon l'erreur des supporters
anglais manifeste fait du club de
liverpool ça a été de refuser le billet
électronique qui reste on le sait dans
tous les stades le meilleur moyen d'
anti-france après comment se fait-il
qu'on n'ait pas anticipé le fait que le
rer b qui celui qui charrie le plus de
monde au stade de france étaient fermées
ça on le savait donc ça s'anticipe
pourquoi les portiques au tout d'un coup
faire entonnoir alors que on aurait pu
répartir à divers points du stade de
france concentrée sur les fameuses
portes x y z bref il ya toutes les
femmes riverains c'est le mot qu'emploie
charles gérald darmanin pour pour
désigner les individus qui sont venus
agresser détrousser
les supporters de liverpool bref une
accumulation qui mérite d'être éclairée
et elle devrait chiffres parce qu'il
n'ya pas trente mille faux billets
visiblement il n' à 2700 parce qu'il
n'ya pas trente mille supporter un
glutineux autour du stade sinon la sncf
et la ratp l'aurait vu donc du coup on a
besoin de transparence en revanche moi
je n'ai pas de crainte pour avoir
couvert de coupe du monde de rugby et
trois éditions des jeux olympiques
ce n'est pas du tout le même contexte
c'est diffus c'est diffus s'est éclatée
sur plusieurs sites au rugby ça se passe
toujours bien aux jeux olympiques que
vous avez un public très averti très
spécialisés qui s'intéressent à telle
discipline n'est pas la globalité donc
il n'y a pas les mêmes risques mais là
on sait que c'était un match à risque on
n'a pas pris les mesures qui
s'imposaient mais en tout cas c'est un
france angleterre l'an prochain à la
coupe du monde ça s'annonce sur un petit
peu tendu ainsi c'est au stade de france
au magasin oui oui
n'importe quelle heure rugby oui c'est
toujours ya vraiment un incident
diplomatique entre la france et qui
justifiait c'est dommage d'ailleurs que
boris johnson n'est pas être sommet
européen hier puisqu'ils ne font plus
partie lui parce que je pense qu'il
aurait quand même envoyé comme on dit on
de tacle glissé
alors effectivement il ya des questions
qui se posent sur cette fraude ces faux
billets qui ont été
produits massivement il ya aussi des
questions sur quand même la stratégie de
sécurité notamment pour les forces de
l'ordre romain gaspard oui c'est c'est
que d'habitude les ces problèmes là et
on les voit depuis les gilet jaune et et
le changement du schéma de maintien de
l'ordre ça se fait lors des manifs et
c'est devant les la population française
là c'est 400 millions de personnes qui
ont vu les des compagnies des compagnies
d'intervention des braves qui sont mis
en avant et qui ont une utilisation des
gaz lacrymogènes qui pose question parce
que dans les vidéos qu'on voit et les
journalistes sur place témoignent que
les les les supporters de liverpool
était plutôt calme et en plus ça
arrivait largement en avance donc il ya
cette question là il ya la question des
nas et de la congestion qu'il ya eu
au niveau 2 à côté de l'autoroute et des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qu'on
a entassé à la sortie du rer d avec des
contrôles policiers qui ont sauté très
très tard là dessus et donc c'est tout
un schéma de maintien de l'ordre et là
la question des choix du préfet de
police de paris didier lallement qui
sont qui sont mis en cause et que la la
la l'audition devant devant le parlement
devrait éclaircir parce que le ministre
répond refuse de répondre sur ce point
et c'est pourtant à mon avis assez
central effectivement on évoque le
ministre 21 ans gérald darmanin mais il
ya un homme en première ligne et qui
pointait du doigt dans ce dossier si le
préfet de police de paris didier
lallement qui est responsable vraiment
de l'organisation nous sur le terrain à
des forces de l'ordre sur sur cet
événement à l'extérieur du stade
pascal jalabert didier la dig allemand
il a été très critiqué durant le
précédent quinquennat et ça s'arrange
pas aujourd'hui non ça se range pas
aujourd'hui alors même s'il n'est pas
critique alors une fois encore l'extrême
droite le critique par rapport au
laxisme vis-à-vis des 10
202 à des bandes de jeunes et des femmes
aux riverains l extrême gauche dit une
fois de plus les policiers ont chargé en
gaz etc rabbo on n'avance pas tant qu'on
est là ce qui est assez révélateur dans
ce fiasco c'est que on a une sorte de
condensé de tous nos problèmes français
vous avez alors un petit bout de
banlieue l'absence de dialogue social
avec la grève la doctrine maintien nord
qui ne fonctionne plus la difficulté à
recruter les stadiers il faut savoir ils
ont été recrutés sur facebook les séries
vous savez ce sont ces personnages et
les jeunes qui assurent la la sécurité
privée c'est à dix ont été recrutés sur
facebook dans la semaine qui a précédé
donc au niveau formation entre 2 et 4
heures
autant dire que qui ne sait pas faire et
certains étaient même aux copains des
riverains sans motif donc voilà bug
informatique vous avez un condensé de
tout
nos petits problèmes qu'on a un petit et
grand preuve qu'on n'arrive pas à
résoudre et qui ont abouti à ce qui
aurait pu être beaucoup plus dramatique
alors là aussi un mois je regrette qu'en
dix ans mais c'est pas grave il n'y a
pas eu de mort c'est pas parce qu'il ya
eu deux morts que ce qui s'est passé
n'est pas important donc on peut espérer
que la commission denquête aïeux
jusqu'au fond des choses et pointe un
parent tous ces dysfonctionnements ah
oui un condensé de tous les hommes de
tous les poulets leur ep selon avec
aussi un contexte politique on est en
pleine campagne des élections
législatives et romain gaspard est ce
qu'il ya un bruit de récupération
politique aussi dans cette affaire oui
c'est une affaire qui permet pour les
oppositions de se positionner et de se
faire entendre mais après aussi une des
erreurs à mon avis c'est la confiance
qu'on peut avoir dans la parole du
ministre de l'intérieur quand il
commence par expliquer d'abord que c'est
la faute des supporters anglais qui sont
en retard et que sur le terrain les
journalistes sur place et les
observateurs par armes de la police de
liverpool font un communiqué pour dire
qu'il était très calme est en avance on
voit qu'il ya un problème factuel dans
ce qui est dit sur le nombre de faux
billets
les chiffres de la sncf et le et le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas eu de mouvement de
foule dans les transports après 21h pose
question donc c'est la confiance qu'on
peut avoir dans la parole publique et
c'est pas une petite question parce que
ça devrait être
rassurant pour tout le monde et est
factuel et aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
et là dessus cette audition aussi
devrait permettre d'éclaircir et et de
se mettre d'accord sur un constat pour
éviter la récupération politique et on
suivra cette audition de ministre de
l'intérieur et des sports de charles de
dharmanand et d'améliorer à castéra au
sénat à 17h en direct sur public sénat
[Musique]